I trust you've had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, but I hope it has been a happy one.
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambhudasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambhudasa
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambuddhasa.
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakenable.
The lights just went off and on, it's interesting.
We'll see what happens.
I thought today we would move on to a different discourse, so this is the one.
We're meeting a character called Panchakanda.
Now, Panchakanda was the carpenter to King Pasenadi, that's in the north of the Ganges, and the Buddha is at Jeta's Grove, Anathapindika's Park.
So if you remember, Anathapindika was a rich merchant who bought him a load of land from a prince called Jeta.
And it says that Panchakanda was his name, but I can't really believe that because it actually means five tools.
And his five tools were an adze.
You might not know what an adze is, but I myself have seen one actually in action.
So I'm very familiar with an adze.
It's like a pick, a small pick, but it's only got the wide end and it's sharp.
and it's used for shaping wood uh crudely in a way uh for instance a a trunk which you want to turn into a square beam so you would use an ads he's got a chisel which is finer he's got a measuring stick uh he's got a gavel a small hammer and he's got a blackened thread uh so that's that's that he probably walked around with those and became known as panchakanga
Anyway, he likes discussion.
He likes to talk about the Dharma and things.
And he was thinking of going to see the Buddha, but he knew he'd be on alms round or something.
So he went to see this other ascetic called Samana Mandikaputta, so the son of Mandika.
So we'll just call him Mandika for short.
And Mandika is in the park, in this particular park, lots of these samanas around him, these recluses, and they're all chatting away.
And when he sees Panchakanta come, he says, sirs, be quiet, sirs, make no noise.
Here comes the carpenter, Panchakanta, a disciple of the recluse, Gautama.
one of the recluses uh white-clothed lay disciples staying at sovereignty that's the capital these venerable ones like quiet they are disciplined in quiet they commend quiet perhaps if he finds our assembly a quiet one he will come to join us so there's this um reputation that uh
the Buddhist monks have that they don't make a noise when they come together.
Now, this silence was taken to a rather far degree because lay people came to the Buddha at one point and said, look,
We approach, you know, the ascetics of other schools and teachers.
We ask them questions and they get into a discussion with us.
But when we ask your monks and nuns questions, they just sit there like dumb pigs.
So he made a rule.
The rule is if somebody asks me a question of the Dharma, I have to answer it.
Or else it's an offence.
Anyway, they've got this reputation and he gets into a conversation with Mandika.
And Mandika tells him that, I describe somebody who's accomplished in what is wholesome, perfected in what is wholesome, attained to the supreme attainment.
an ascetic invincible with these four qualities.
He does no evil bodily actions.
He does no evil speech.
He has no evil intentions.
And he does not make a living by any evil livelihood.
So Panchakanga just listens in either approved or disapproved.
And he wanders away thinking, well, I'll see what the blessings one thinks about that.
So he goes to see the Blessed One and he repeats this.
And the Blessed One replies, the Buddha replies, well, now, if this were so, carpenter, then a young, tender infant lying prone is accomplished in what is wholesome, perfected in what is wholesome, attained to the supreme attainment and ascetic invincible.
For a young, tender infant lying prone does not even have the notion body.
So how could he do, how could he perform an evil act?
beyond mere wriggling.
A young tender infant lying prone does not even have the notion speech.
So how should he utter evil speech beyond mere whining?
A young tender infant lying prone does not even have the notion intention.
So how could he have evil intentions apart from sulking?
A young tender infant prone does not even have the notion
livelihood so how could he make his living by evil livelihood beyond being suckled at his mother's breast so if that were so carpenter then a young tender infant lying prone is accomplished etc etc and an in an ascetic invincible so that's the uh the buddha's opinion of uh
mandika's understanding of what it is to be uh to be fully liberated uh then having demolished that he now he now begins to tell us that uh he tells patrick anger that in fact there are 10 qualities um that i i describe as accomplished in what is wholesome as the lights again a message from the gods uh
So the first one is, a person knows these are unwholesome habits.
Unwholesome habits originate from this.
Unwholesome habits cease without remainder here.
And one practicing in this way is practicing the way to the cessation of unwholesome habits.
So that, of course, is a sign of somebody who's liberated.
And he also says these are wholesome habits.
So we have wholesome habits.
Wholesome habits originate from this and wholesome habits cease without remainder here.
So even wholesome habits come to an end.
Now, where do unwholesome habits originate?
They originate from the mind right now.
This word citta is really heart-mind.
So whenever you read mind here in Bhikkhu Bodhi's translations and in others too, remember it always includes your emotional life, your emotional commitment to things.
So the mind is multiple, varied, and of different aspects there is a mind which is affected by greed, hatred, and delusion.
And wholesome habits originate from this, right?
Where do one wholesome habits cease without remainder?
Here, a person abandons bodily misconduct, develops good bodily conduct, abandons verbal misconduct and develops good verbal conduct.
He abandons mental misconduct and develops good mental
conduct how practicing does he practice the way to the cessation what does he do and these of course are the four right efforts the first one is he awakens zeal for the non-arising of unarisen evil states in other words uh to make sure that evil that unwholesome states don't arise and then when they do arise he arrived he awakened zeal to abandon them
When wholesome states arise, he awakens zeal for their continuance, not their disappearance, strengthening, increase and fulfillment by developing them.
And of course, he makes an effort and strives to bring new wholesome mental states to bear.
And it's the same with the wholesome states too.
This is what he does, right?
So it's always the four great efforts, whether it's wholesome or unwholesome states.
Now, we're talking about, at the end he says, where do these wholesome habits cease without remainder?
Their cessation is stated.
Here a bhikkhu is virtuous, but he does not identify with his virtue.
And he understands as he actually is the deliverance of mind and the deliverance by wisdom, where these wholesome habits cease without remainder.
So now we come to the Arahant, somebody who's completed the path.
And he says they are deliverance of mind.
Now, the deliverance of mind is, of course, a purity, the deliverance from the taints, those oozings.
And the deliverance by wisdom, of course, is the direct insight into the way things really are.
Now, at that point, when an Arahant speaks or thinks or does something, it has this special quality of there not being a self involved, of there not being an attachment involved.
So it's a very pure, spontaneous action.
You can't aim to be spontaneous.
The whole point about spontaneity is that it arises spontaneously.
And they have in the Abhidharma, the higher teaching, they have a special word for the actions of
And that is kriya, which translates as sort of functional.
So long as we are unawakened, unenlightened, our actions will always have some quality of self.
If they're unwholesome, of course, we don't want them.
But even when they are wholesome actions, there'll be some attachment.
There'll be some identification with the action.
So by practicing these four great efforts, this is how we come to the end of both
wholesome and unwholesome, wholesome and unwholesome, and wholesome actions.
So the words in Pali are kusala, akusala, wholesome, unwholesome, and then the special category for those who are completely liberated, kriya, or functional.
And then he goes on about wholesome intentions.
So unwholesome intentions.
So the first are actions and the second one is intentions, unwholesome and wholesome intentions.
So these intentions are, of course, for sensual desire, ill will and the intention for cruelty.
So this is the second on the Eightfold Path, if you remember, the right intention or right attitude.
And where do these originate?
They originate in perception.
They originate in perception and concepts.
So an intention is always something ahead of you.
You're always looking into the future.
There we go again.
That's the lights.
Thank you very much.
You're always looking into the future.
And therefore, it comes from some idea, some ideation, some ideal.
You're always working towards some perception of where you're going to go.
that's why an intention is based on perceptions and it's of course multiple varied of different aspects and but then but you can you can draw them down in terms of unwholesome ones to sensual desire ill will and cruelty now where do they cease well they cease by through believe it or not meditation quiet secluded from sensual pleasures secluded from unwholesome states
A person abides in the first jhana.
So the first absorption pushes these down.
Remember, they don't cure them, right?
They don't get rid of unwholesome states.
That can only be done through allowing them to come up into consciousness and to expend their energy.
That's part of the process of vipassana.
But here, at least temporarily, they are suppressed.
Now, what are wholesome intentions?
Well, they are, of course, the opposite.
Renunciation, instead of always grasping and acquisitiveness, non-ill will, which includes all these things about love and all that, you see, and goodwill, and the intention not to be cruel, which, of course, leads you to compassion.
And again, they arise out of perception.
They arise out of concepts.
They arise out of ideals because an intention is always future bound.
And of course, they finish without remainder.
So where do they go without remainder?
So that, of course, again, we're talking about the Arahant.
We're talking about someone who's fully liberated.
And that comes about through...
partly through the practice of jhana, but in our practice of dry vipassana, pure vipassana, it comes about through practice again.
So again, and of course, you awaken the zeal to stop unarisen, unwholesome intentions to arise.
And when unwholesome intentions do arise, you abandon them.
When wholesome intentions come up, you, of course, exercise them and you try to develop even more in wholesomeness.
So we have a final paragraph that sums up for us the ten qualities that are needed for somebody who is perfected in what is wholesome, attained to supreme attainment and is an ascetic invincible.
So the first eight I think you'll recognize.
Here the bhikkhu possesses right view.
of one beyond training, the right view of an arahat, the right intention of one beyond training, the right speech of one beyond training, the right action of one beyond training, the right livelihood, the right effort, the right mindfulness and the right concentration.
But also the number nine and number ten is right knowledge and right deliverance.
So right knowledge, of course, is that direct perception of the deathless.
And the right deliverance is, of course, from the taints, the oozings.
And this is the way the Buddha describes someone who's accomplished
in what is wholesome perfected, in what is wholesome attained in the supreme attainment, an ascetic invincible.
That's what the Blessed One said, and the carpenter Panchakanda was satisfied and delighted in the Blessed One's words.
So we've met another character from our discourses, and hopefully you've also found that.
in some way inspiring, I hope, and that it will drive you relentlessly towards your liberation, which will happen hopefully sooner rather than later.
So we can do a bit of practice.
And don't worry about the lights coming off and on.
It's just one of those things we are suffering at the moment.